okay before I start I just want to say I
just saw in the credits that Tenzin was
played by JK sinem Simmons never would
have guessed that uh Wow kudos he's won
those guys we sir know he's a good actor
but he served does the you know give me
the picture so spider-man you know sort
of that voice and that carried over and
over the guy behind the desk oh oh I'm
the tough guy behind the desk oh and
yeah just nice range I really would have
guessed that was Emmett he did a he did
a real good job he's doing a real good
job with this character so I'm impressed
um but okay so we have this this episode
cold and the winner is uh which is
better than the last one um you know if
you remember the last one I wasn't a big
fan of uh and we do have this bending
competition but they mix it in with the
terrorists with a mom coming in and at
the same time like there are a lot of it
I'm saying really with all that police
protection you couldn't find these
people bring it in these whatever these
cheap blocking gloves now which those
are cool I love the fact that there's a
device it's like now it can be actually
put into mechanics you know the block
the chains die I think that's great um
and really all the cops were taken out
and nobody they seemed to have radio
that nobody could contact it I don't
know but that's that's part of the
nitpicking thing you know the terrorists
are gonna get in they're just gonna do
it whatever um and there's also a little
bit with corner seems to be it's like
she's rushing and all this stuff and she
wants to fight and everything and you
know it's all about her journey but at
the same time it's like her goof ups are
really starting to add up I'm thinking
like in the big climax here you had um
one moment where she I don't even know
what happens like she tries to rise out
of the water to get them they're going
onto the blimp and she's trying to catch
him on and she just stops and starts
falling I don't know that meant like she
ran out of water or what maybe you'll be
addressed
the next episode I don't know uh and
then the other one is like she steps in
wrong place the glass breaks and the
what's the name of Tom's daughter
whatever you know is gonna get on the
ship and kick all sorts of ass and then
looks down and sees that she's falling
so she has to die down and get her as
she stays there twice pretty much in
this and I don't know it's like she has
her cool badass moments and everything
but at the same time it's sort of it's a
little too evened out with how many
times she kind of Boches up um it's I
mean it's not all the time everything
but it might be one too many for me
um but all right so else happens in this
episode you got you find out the history
of why um I'll get her name in the next
one bad toss daughter and just go car
now uh why she is so aggressive against
the avatar now and you know because um
her and Tenzin had this um I had a
history you know which is great and I
love the little bit where he's gonna go
into the history and says why am I
telling you this it was a great comedic
moment uh and even when they had like
the whatever the losing team when they
had the the possums like tied up down
below they didn't leave a person there
to look after them in case oh I don't
know a swimming possum comes and bites
through the ropes unlikely as that is
still you should probably have a guard
there but I think that's nitpicking
um yeah get show you you know you a
little bit of that um but you know this
doesn't feel that much like a kids show
it does not give in to I should say
given but it doesn't do a lot of the
stuff that you normally see in say I
haven't are the last airbender II you
know where there's a lot of that comedy
um or if there is it's not quite as good
or it sort of varies so I don't know it
seems like in many respects they're
really upping their game like I said for
sort of the interesting and wants a
commentary but don't touch um sort of
social commentary they're talking about
with sort of the new problems that can
arise after you know quote-unquote peace
is spread throughout the land
and in the new troubles but I don't know
is some of this I like the show don't
get me wrong but it's not it's not quite
meshing as well as I feel it could a lot
of times or I feel like you know with
this episode when the when a man finally
comes in and says you know we're at war
and stuff yeah it's like okay let's get
going and then the episode stops it
always seems like once it's gonna start
getting going then it stops and it goes
to something else it's always like let's
let's get moving come on um you know
it's only 12 episodes also so it's like
I think there's this great anxious side
of me at least that really wants to see
the adventure going and wants to see you
know the real the real story begin and
the real drama and we've had enough set
up you know let's really get this moving
and every single time it looks like it's
start it's on you go to the pro-bending
thing or you go to the love triangle or
you go to her learning some more and
that's all fine but I think less
Airbender got I hate I hate referring
the wiser but I I hate doing that
because you don't be want you don't want
be one of those people it's like it's
not avatar is net the Nets Airbender and
I'm not looking for that I'm totally
open to the fact this is something new
and different and I like all the
different changes that they're doing uh
but yeah I think there is a pacing issue
where it's like you know it really
should get going you know it seems like
it's really the only thing I can think
of as the Harry Potter films which I
know a lot of people like the Harry
Potter films I think they're boring is
fuck you know cuz it's just like it
could be it could be told in three books
guy so it can be told in three movies
and it's like no in this episode we're
getting closer to the story and this
this movie we're getting closer to this
Arion this one we're getting even close
it's like no just go you have enough
build-up let's just go into it uh but I
get Harry Potter is tremendously
successful maybe they're looking to do
something similar um so Who am I to say
you know don't Harry Potter it cuz Harry
Potter is like one of the biggest you
know phenomenons that's ever happened
uh so I don't know for me it's ironic
cuz it's only 12 episodes but for me it
just it seems like it's going very slow
and it's focusing on stuff some stuff
that should be given a little bit more
time or at least spread out I should say
some stuff that should really be spread
out
it is sort of rushed and other stuff
that's rush should probably have a
little bit more time spent on it so I
don't know it's I mean I'm like I'm not
disliking it but I would like to see I
want to see it balanced out a little bit
more um but you know it's still good
stuff you know I'm still even though the
core care can get to me I still like the
character I still want to see her
succeed I like that she does Liz I like
that when uh you know when they say look
the ref is obviously bought off let's
play dirty back and they say you know no
don't do that they're gonna get us you
know let's play fair and she says I
don't want to but okay and she does I
like that you know cuz I swear if she
did a cheatin move I was gonna be like
okay I am like done with this character
this character never friggin learns but
you know she did she played within the
rules and I like that so she does she
does learn she does evolve it's just
some of these missteps maybe just one or
two many you know just a few too many
missteps for me um but I'm still with it
uh the comedy you wanted when it works
does work god I love the scene where the
the announcer gets tasered that killed
one of them is in the booth with me now
folks he has one of those strange
electric gauntlet things I think he's
going to shock me I am wetting myself
right now
Larry anything with that guy is
wonderful also like that cabbage Corp
thing that I think they're implying that
like the cabbage salesman like started
this huge technological empire somehow
um I wasn't reading too deep into it but
why are they called cabbage Corp so uh
so I don't know I'm still with it and
there's still a lot to be impressed by
the fight scene at the very end is very
impressive I love the the feelin is
awesome I love what they're doing to
villain I want I want to say I want more
of him but I
no they should keep him just just the
amount they're showing it is actually
perfect were you sort of longed for more
oven but you know you're actually
getting the perfect amount so I won't
that won't push for that but yeah I mean
it it's still it's still good and it's
holding my attention but yeah it's like
let's let's go let's you know really get
get moving here you know the the war has
begun okay now me at this time really
begin this war really get it going uh so
yeah that's about it um you know if this
episode was maybe two three episodes
earlier I'd probably like it more
because it's like okay here we go but um
you know gas a room for love triangles
and such but whatever I'm still curious
I still want to see where it's going so
uh yeah that's about it and see you next
episode